[Music]
gray is with us in tampa florida hi gray
welcome to the show
hi thank you for having me hi rachel hi
dave sure how can we help
um so
i finally well my wife and i finally got
scared enough um and mad enough at our
debt to stop our plan and start your
plan
and i have heard you mention in the past
there's a couple of things that you
recommend
before baby step one i believe it's term
life insurance and identity theft um
maybe a will and the biggest part of
this is
if we are behind on our bills so there's
a couple like a car payment and one
credit card we're behind on is that do
we get current before saving the
thousand or do we save the thousand like
crazy and then get current
um okay the will the term insurance and
um the identity theft insurance are just
simply not a baby step so it's not the
thing you have to do those before you
start the baby steps but they're all
something you need to do as soon as you
can
okay but it might be that you're deep
into baby step two before you actually
implement those
uh i wouldn't say you have to get those
done before you start baby step one as
far as getting caught up on your bills
yeah i would get caught up on your bills
um and that's your that's your first
thing let's get to even let's get to
even and uh the good news is you've
already started concentrating on this
and so when you do this month's budget
you'll probably get even won't you
yes it'll probably be about three weeks
to get evening yeah okay
all right so what happened gray i'm
curious for you guys you said we got mad
enough and scared enough um
what was well i got the
biggest paycheck um single week paycheck
in the history of my life
and it wasn't enough to pay all of our
bills
and
i i was scared my wife was scared
the day before we got the paycheck
because she saw how much it was going to
be and said that's not enough
and
then i heard a debt free pre-scream from
some people last week that they had a
construction company they sold like
kitchen counters or something and in
three years they paid off over a million
and i was like that's it i see the light
at the end of the tunnel we can do this
and um eventually we won't have to be
scared but right now we're scared but
there's a solution that's not ours that
we can get there yeah how old are you
guys
i am 31 and my wife is 32. how long you
been married
four years okay how much are your car
payments
um
one vehicle is
340 dollars and the other vehicle is
360. okay
probably need to sell one of them
okay
you got 700 car payments what's your
household income
uh take home about 63 000 a year i know
you need to sell one of them
okay and you you get to pick which one
but it's probably yours not hers so
that's definitely my pickup truck okay
so here's the thing um you said like
five times that you're scared and it's a
good scared because it's the kind of
scared that says i got to get out of the
middle of the road a truck's coming
right that's a good scared
um
but with that um
i've been where you are and i remember
how it feels to have your stomach in
your throat
and not be able to breathe
and i know how terrified my wife was and
we were your age
okay
so number one
piece of information that you need to
tell your wife tonight
number one cause of divorce in north
america today of money pro
of marital fights marital discord
is money stress number one cause
and you're square in the middle of it
and that terror that she feels and that
hit on your self-esteem that you feel
because you can't seem to get it
together up until today
okay
is uh
they feed on each other she's afraid
her claws come out that makes you feel
less when you feel less that makes her
more afraid and it's a really vicious
circle okay so you guys have to look at
each other take her hands in your hands
give her a big hug and go okay
we're doing this together um we are not
going to live like this anymore and we
are not going to let this take our
marriage and as a matter of fact it's
going to make our marriage stronger
but you have to say it out loud okay
i i can do that and we can do that yeah
because i i don't want that to sneak up
on you because even if you had a even if
you thought you had a really good
marriage and you met you may you may but
this is the ultimate stressor
on a marriage so just know that you know
if the number one people way people die
in your area is bear attack
there is a bear in your living room okay
and so you go oh this is a problem it's
the number one thing right so um yeah
really don't let the bear in the living
room and so um that's what you got to do
you got to put your arms around her and
hold on tight for the ride now we're
going to put you into ramsay plus which
will plug you into financial peace
university i want you to go through the
classes together we'll put you in every
dollar the premium app it's part of it
too or you can do the budget together
and and there's gonna be a lot of people
in there that are facing the same kind
of stuff you're facing we'll put you
into a group it's all on us we're gonna
pay for it because i've been where
you've been the only thing i request is
that you do everything we tell you to do
and you go when
and then the second thing is someday
when you're rich you give it to some
young couple that's scared okay
absolutely thank you so much for your
generosity
and if you get scared and you don't know
what to do on some little detail thing
as you're working this you call us again
we're here for you okay
okay thank you all right god bless you
brother
that's uh
that's most people
yeah
yep
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck when you drive down the street
eight out of 10 houses on your street
have too much month left at the end of
the money normal in the this country
today is broke and that sucks
it's not okay
it's not okay
and that's the bad news the good news is
you can do something about it
you get to wake up every day make a
decision and i love even the the selling
the car so mathematically absolutely but
there's almost this like jilt in your
system that you need when you've been
doing the same thing even though it's
wrong over and over and over and over
you become comfortable you become
familiar with it
and it's almost like when you change
course and you do something like this
and you just do something that feels
radical and he's like oh it's going to
be my truck selling the truck like it's
going to hurt it's not going to be fun
but you're going to buy my credit cards
i'm going to sell the truck i'm not
going out to eat i'm going to do some
radical stuff i'm not living like this
anymore ah
you got to have that thing happen down
inside of you
when you do
you'll be ready baby and we're here to
help we can show you how
but uh you can you can wander into debt
but you can't wander out it's not an
intellectual exercise you got to get so
pissed off you can't breathe i'm getting
out
and that's right where he is he's scared
and he's mad and oh that's a really good
place to be this is the ramsey show